it's great to welcome back to the
program Catherine Stewart who's the
author of the power worshippers inside
the dangerous rise of religious
nationalism Catherine so great to have
you back it's wonderful to see you again
thank you so I think that now partially
thanks to this Netflix series the family
there are more people who are becoming
familiar with the under-the-radar way in
which Christian nationalism is a thing
here in the United States despite sort
of at least nominally the separation of
church and state and one of the things a
lot of people may not understand is all
of the different sort of centers of
power and influence that that are
playing a role here so can you kind of
lay out the landscape for us a little
bit sure
the political movements are pretty
complicated and this one is I think more
complex than most most it's kind of
central is it consists of a variety of
for-profit and nonprofit organizations
legal advocacy groups right-wing policy
groups Data initiatives media and
messaging workshops legislative
initiatives so you know the movements
leaders are there are a number of them
they're often interconnected through
some of these initiatives but it's it's
a really vast kind of movement with a
lot of different components and it shows
the extent to which this the Christian
Right has organized over decades really
in building this kind of infrastructure
can you give a couple of the examples
that might be more surprising to people
of where what what some of the
components are sure I mean let's start
with the legislative initiative called
Project blitz it's it operates a little
bit like the American Legislative
Exchange Council if you know what that
is they craft centrally craft
legislation and then these different
pieces of identical or near identical
legislation or they flood the states all
of them intending to sort of chip away
bit by bit at the separation of church
and state in different ways so for
instance this past year and a half and
dozens of states have seen these in god
we trust' bills which mandate that
people put large in god we trust'
science in public school classrooms in
public schools even on public buildings
even in the windows of police cars just
to sort of get the idea in people's
minds you know In God We Trust this is
somehow you know unifying the idea of
religion with a national identity but
you know when they these in God We Trust
bills come into a state people think
it's sort of a one-off and maybe they
oppose it or maybe they don't but the
fact is these are pieces of pieces of
legislation that are crafted by project
blitz and so then one thing I'm thinking
of is when when bans on same-sex
marriage were effectively outlawed by
the Supreme Court in June of 2015 we we
talked at the time about how the battle
lines against LGBT rights were going to
shift from marriage to workplace
discrimination so-called religious
freedom and then a whole bunch of
different instances of this popped up at
the state level was that also an example
of the way in which this is this is
crafted and then kind of rolled out
nationally absolutely I mean as the
architects of project blitz have
arranged this type of legislation to
three categories the first is more you
know you could call it symbolic but the
third category is really about license
to discriminate against people whose
so-called lifestyles are very being that
they disapprove of so opposition to LGBT
equality is on the front lines of that
third category when we talk about this
concept of the culture war religiosity
seems to be a big part of that I mean
very often when we talk about like the
more religious and older FoxNews
demographic and how it ties into very
often supporting Republican agenda
rather than Democratic agenda can you
talk a little bit about how you think of
the concept of cultural war in this
concept context of religiosity sure I
mean I think we're kidding ourselves if
we just look at this through a culture
war frame
work the this is a political movement
and it's all about power and if you look
at the expansiveness of the positions of
the leaders look when they're talking to
the you know the voters or when they're
talking to pastors about how to talk to
their congregants about these issues to
turn them out to vote there it's all
abortion all the time or it's some of
these others seem you know same-sex
marriage or these other kinds of
cultural war issues but when you look at
what they say in the forms that they
share when they're talking to
sympathetic audiences they have
incredibly expansive policy proposals
economic policy foreign policy domestic
policy and that shows that this is a
much more expansive movement it's not
just a culture war I mean if you can
they understand really well that if you
can get people to vote on one or two
issues you can capture their vote so
that's why they've focused so heavily on
these on these particular issues you
know in in the coronavirus situation
that we're dealing with we've seen a lot
of prominent Christian televangelists
preying on vulnerable people on their
disproportionately elderly audiences
offering things like silver you can
drink to cure coronavirus ken that's Jim
Baker Kenneth Copeland did a sort of
pray away coronavirus thing with his
hands covered in I mean I'm guessing
it's water but some sort of holy liquid
I'm sure is that that's a very
cartoonish representation of the
connection between news and religion
does that have any connection to the to
the movement you are talking about which
is working legislatively etc or are
these really two totally different
things and no it's all connected look
the movement is deeply hostile it's very
anti science they you know obviously or
anti evolution very take very strong
most segments of the movement take very
strong anti environmental policies
because that's sort of part of their
policy it's a very sort of pro-business
you know business friendly of a movement
because they depend critically on the
wealth of a subsection of America's
plutocratic class
so they do take anti environmental
policies they take in anti science
policies and they and they disparage
critical thinking above all and so that
movement has really kind of taken
control of the Republican Party and I
think you see the consequences in the
administration's reaction to the corona
virus and pandemic like this where were
unable to sort of there's a kind of
diminishment of value of expertise you
know the people who are around in
Trump's inner circle they're not chosen
because they're experts in their field
they're chosen because they adhere to an
extremist ideology and because they've
demonstrated like severe political like
extreme political loyalty
so we're talk a little bit about you
mentioned that political divide right
Republicans and Democrats on the one
hand there's no question that in the
electorate this is far more prevalent on
the right than on the left at the same
time things like the National Prayer
Breakfast and you know prayer from from
a chaplain before the house starts this
stuff is basically codified and not
really questioned very much by
Republicans or Democrats so can you talk
a little bit about where there is a
partisan divide on this and then where
there is not well I think most Democrats
support the separation of church and
state and understand that it's not just
a sort of a technicality in our
Constitution and it's not just something
for atheists it's a principle that
served our country very well since our
nation's founding the kind of respect
for religious pluralism America is
irreducibly pluralistic and I think that
that's become a kind of partisan issue
respect for pluralism or the desire to
impose a sort of single improved
approved varieties of religion on them
on the rest of us and to create within
America kind of hierarchy or a hierarchy
of rights at the same time though again
we see that there are these elements you
know everything from the prayer before
the house comes to order and the
National Prayer Breakfast where the
lines seem more blurred in terms of that
separation I'm wondering whether the
movements you talked about
are they specifically targeting
Republicans or are they simply having
sort of more success with them how does
that work that movement is really seize
control of the Republican Party let's
just look at the issues like abortion
when roe v wade was passed most
Republicans supported it most Republican
Protestants supported it and there were
a Republican pro-choice organizations up
into the 90s or early 2000s but bit by
bit they were purged because that sort
of extreme wing seize control of the
party they knew that it was like easier
in a way to unite a smaller group around
a radical core than it is to unite more
disparate group of folks and create you
know cohesion there I mean look it's
absolutely true that religion there's
always been religion our country freedom
of religion is one of our founding
principles and freedom of conscience and
it's worth noting I think that there's a
very strong progressive religious
movement in America that rejects the
politics of conquest and division that
this movement represents what are the
other issues I mean it's obvious that
abortion and gay marriage have recently
been been very very prominent you sort
of alluded to religious messages in
civil society in god we trust'
everywhere room currency Pledge of
Allegiance etc what are some of the
other policy issues that this movement
is concerned with and pushing for well
they're always talking about religious
freedom of religious liberty and it's a
kind of spacious idea of freedom that
the religious freedom is your is the
right of people with the so-called
correct view supposedly correct views to
discriminate against others but I think
that calls for a religious freedom are
as loud an assistant as they are not
just because people with the correct
views want the right to discriminate
against others and to destroy basically
you know various forms of equal rights
and civil rights legislation but also
because they're really desperate to
secure their tax subsidies and to expand
access to public money so let's think
about it this way religious
organizations already enjoy substantial
tax privileges and benefits and
subsidies and other religious No
religious nonprofits do not enjoy their
parsonage exemptions they don't have to
open their book so the taxpayer can see
where the money goes once you know when
they have it so so they get all these
exemptions and subsidies and yet they're
still eager to seize a greater share of
public money so this is really obvious
I'll just give you one example the field
of public education America spent
something like I don't know six hundred
billion dollars every year in public K
through 12 the movement is really
desperate to see but sees an even
greater portion of that than they are
have through vouchers so they're you
know there's already voucher programs
throughout many states I'm thinking like
of state of Florida where 80% of the
voucher money flows into religious
schools which are free to discriminate
against LGBT students and teachers that
are free to promote creationism and to
teach kind of contempt for other forms
of religion some of them teach a kind of
Christian nationalist version of
American history so there's a but they
they just want to sees more more and
more money and now there's a case in
front of the Supreme Court I think it's
called a it's it took place in Montana I
can the name escapes me right now but
it's another case where observers are
noting that this may open the floodgates
to even more tax pending funding for
religious organizations so you write
about like a three-phase agenda and you
talk to phase one is stuff like In God
We Trust on bills and on police cars etc
no this is just for project blitz itself
that's not for the movement overall god
magic blitz is only one small of a much
larger and much larger well even better
I mean give us a sense of what is the
broader plan so you know that the micro
we're talking about this in god we
trust' type stuff
it seems more macro is for example
getting getting of state money for
schooling that can discriminate on
religious grounds what's the big picture
well it's a nationalist authoritarian
anti-democratic movement and I think
that's kind of the bigger picture here
that this is a movement that
trice is trying to bring about a
different kind of order they don't think
a lot of people think of the religious
right and they think well they just kind
of want to see at the table and they
want you know in the form of noisy form
of American democracy they just want to
have their voices heard and be taken
into account but this is a movement that
really doesn't believe in my you know
modern pluralistic democracy with equal
rights for all they really want to
establish a more authoritarian form of
power so let's look at it we can compare
it to other forms of religious
nationalism around the world when you
look at what Vladimir Putin is doing in
Russia or or Bonn in Hungary or air21 in
Turkey
when these leaders bind themselves
closely to conservative religious
authorities in their own countries in
order to establish a more authoritarian
form of power we rightly recognize this
as a form of religious nationalism and I
think that this is what we're seeing
today with trump's alliance with our own
religious hyper conservatives yet that
in the limited time we have left i
wanted to ask you know trump was has not
been known to be a religious person for
basically his entire life all of a
sudden the bibles his favorite book and
so on and so forth how much is Trump a
sort of controlled by this is completely
because he's dependent on them for his
power
I mean they've managed to get a lock on
a bloc of voters and without their
support he would have failed and I think
when you look at these alliance with
them a lot of people think it's
transactional they think he's just gonna
appoint justices favorable to their
interests or economic policies favorable
to their pocketbooks but I think it goes
further than that I mean Trump I sort of
personifies a certain kind of
authoritarian power that the move delete
that you know religious nationalism
often favors religious nationalism
doesn't want a nice leader they want a
leader who's gonna sort of break the
rules and and knock heads as long as
those heads belong to their their
so-called enemies yes and we're seeing
that weekly if not daily with with this
administration we've been speaking with
Catherine Stewart the book is the power
worshippers inside the dangerous rise of
religious national
Catherines such a pleasure having you
back on thanks so much for having me